Тетяна, мама 13-річної школярки,
вже не один тиждень полює на вакцину від кору.
А у Вас є прививки
від кору?
Ні, на жаль, немає.
А коли будуть?
Не підкажу, обіцяли на цьому тижні.
От бачите не має.
Планові щеплення доньці треба було зробити ще у шестилітньому віці.
Однак тоді, каже, пропустили, бо вакцини не було.
А коли з’явилася - то ніхто не нагадав.
Лише цьогорічний спалах кору нагадав
про ризики такого недогляду.
Хвилююся, звичайно,
бо дуже багато не ревакцинованих дітей,
і я вважаю, що це не правильно.
У 2016 році було щеплено менше половини дітей,
тоді як для підтримки колективного імунітету
рівень вакцинації має бути не нижчим 98%.
Серед причин зриву планових щеплень, зокрема,
і масові кампанії проти вакцинації,
кажуть чиновники з мінохоронздоров‘я.
Щодо самої вакцини, то в МОЗ запевняють,
що закуповують для України найкращі бельгійські препарати.
Їхню придатність легко перевірити:
якщо білий квадрат на упаковці потьмянів - температурний режим
було порушено і вакцину більше
не можна використовувати.
За даними МОЗ, в Україні нині є понад півмільйона вакцин
проти кору. Ще мільйон одиниць надійде у квітні.
Області звертаються до МОЗ,
і ми робимо перерозподіл з інших областей,
де є додаткові дози.
Ми вже це зробили для Києва. Ми побачили,
що в останні два тижні дуже багато людей привели своїх дітей
на вакцинацію,  бо дотепер в Києві
була потреба.
Слова очільниці мінохоронздоров‘я підтверджують і у столичних державних лікарнях -
вакцин вистачає, аби тільки охочі були.
Не знаю, може, десь і немає, а у нас вакцин достатньо:
і на вакцинацію, і на ревакцинацію. 200 вакцин приблизно є.
Однак на Закарпатті - де, як і в Івано-Франківську
та Одесі, зафіксовано найбільше
випадків захворювання - препаратів проти кору бракує.
Про це пише голова Закарпатської ОДА.
Аби в подальшому проблем з розподілом не виникало,
у МОЗ - в рамках медичної реформи - працюють
над впровадженням електронного реєстру вакцин та дітей,
які їх потребують. Це допоможе також подолати
й іншу проблему - недостовірні довідки від лікарів
про буцімто проведені щеплення, що також
впливає на загальну статистику.
Все буде зафіксовано по електронній картці пацієнта,
там буде вже
інший рівень покарання,
якщо є підроблені медичні факти.
Це буде не лише з боку лікаря,
але й пацієнта.
Згідно з медичною реформою, безкоштовні вакцини можна буде отримати і в приватних клініках.
Якщо цей заклад підпише контракт з державною службою страховки.
Ці зміни полегшить життя таким батькам,
як Тетяна, які обирають не державні
лікувальні заклади. А поки вона сподівається, що вже
наступного тижня вакцина з'явиться
і дочку, нарешті, вдасться прищепити.